FOR THE VICTIMS WHO ARE THE
REAL VICTIMS.
THAT’S THE FOE CONSULTATION
OF TONIGHT’S ANGLE.
HAVE YOU HEARD THE MEDIA OFF
FAWN ALL OVER CAPITOL HILL’S
LATEST IMMIGRATION PLAN?
IT’S BEING BILLED AS A
BIPARTISAN APPROACH WHICH IS
A COMPLETE JOKE SINCE ITS
SPONSORS ARE AMNESTY ZEALOT
JOHN MCCAIN OF ARIZONA AND
LIBERAL DELAWARE SENATOR
CHRIS COONS.
THIS BILL IS BASICALLY A
RERUN OF THE FAILED GANG OF
8 FIASCO THAT FLOPPED OUT IN
2013.
REMEMBER THAT LEGISLATION
WAS SO UNPOPULAR THAT EVEN
ITS ORIGINAL SPONSOR MARCO
RUBIO HAD TO WALK IT BACK
AND NOW HE CONSIDERS IT A
BIG MISTAKE.
SO GANG OF 82.0 WOULD GRANT
LEGAL STATUS AND A PATH TO
CITIZENSHIP TO YOUNG
MIGRANTS WHO CAME HERE
BEFORE 2014.
AND THAT IS A NUMBER THAT
FAR EXCEEDS THE 1.8 MILLION
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
WILLING TO MAKE CITIZENS IN
HIS COMPROMISE GESTURE.
AND THERE WOULD BE NO BORDER
WALL FUNDING.
AND IT WOULD KEEP CHAIN
MIGRATION, THAT ENTIRE SCAM
WOULD KEEP GOING.
SO, OBVIOUSLY, THIS IS A
COMPLETE NONSTARTER FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE, MEANING, MCCAIN
COONS WAS A STUPID PLOY, NOT
A SERIOUS PLAN.
LAWMAKERS WHO HAVE BEEN
SHOPPING VARIOUS AMNESTIES
FOR YEARS FOCUSED MOST OF
THEIR EMPATHY AND CONCERN ON
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WHO FEAR
DEPORTATION.
NOT ON AMERICANS WHOSE LIVES
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT CRIME.
PRESIDENT TRUMP, HOWEVER,
HASN’T FORGOTTEN THOSE
PEOPLE AND TODAY HE FOCUSED
ON CLOSING IMMIGRATION
LOOPHOLES TO KEEP GROUPS
LIKE MS-13 OUT OF OUR
COUNTRY.
AS FOR THE DEMOCRATS
REFUSING TO COME TO THE
TABLE, TRUMP IS WILLING TO
PLAY HARD BALL.
>> IF WE DON’T CHANGE THE
LEGISLATION, IF WE DON’T GET
RID OF THESE LOOPHOLES WHERE
KILLERS ARE ALLOWED TO COME
INTO OUR COUNTRY AND
CONTINUE TO KILL GANG
MEMBERS, AND WE’RE JUST
TALKING ABOUT MS-13.
THERE ARE MANY GANG MEMBERS
THAT WE DON’T EVEN MENTION.
IF WE DON’T CHANGE IT, LET’S
HAVE A SHUT DOWN.
WE WILL DO A SHUT DOWN AND
IT’S WORTH IT FOR OUR
COUNTRY.
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE A SHUT
DOWN IF WE DON’T GET THIS
STUFF TAKEN CARE OF.
>> Laura: THE LEFT IS GOING
CRAZY BECAUSE HE SAID THAT
BUT THAT’S HOW MUCH HE CARES
ABOUT THE COUNTRY.
HE CARES ABOUT OUR SAFETY,
THE RULE OF LAW.
THE PRESIDENT KNOWS THAT THE
PEOPLE ARE WITH HIM ON THIS
ISSUE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE POLL
NUMBERS, AMERICANS WANT
SENSIBLE IMMIGRATION REFORMS
ALONG WITH MAYBE CURING THE
DACA PROBLEM, OKAY.
HERE’S A RECENT HARVARD
HARRIS POLL.
IT FOUND THAT 65% OF VOTERS
AGREED THAT ANY BILL
GRANTING LEGAL STATUS TO
DREAMERS SHOULD BE
ACCOMPANIED BY FUNDING FOR A
WALL, AN END TO CHAIN
MIGRATION, AS WELL AS AN END
TO THE VISA LOTTERY SYSTEM.
53% SUPPORTED BUILDING A
BORDER WALL CONSISTING OF
PHYSICAL AND ELECTRONIC
BARRIERS.
AND A WHOPPING 79% WANTED
IMMIGRATION TO BE BASED ON
MERIT, NOT ON FAMILY
CONNECTIONS OR OTHER
FACTORS.
WELL, I’M ASSUMING NEITHER
SENATOR FROM ARIZONA
BOTHERED TO CONSIDER THE NEW
COMPREHENSIVE STUDY BY
ECONOMIST JOHN LOT WHO WILL
JOIN US LATER IN THE SHOW.
PROFESSOR LOT BASICALLY
LOOKED AT ALL THE ILLEGAL I
WHO ENTERED THE ARIZONA
STATE PRISON SYSTEM FROM THE
YEARS 1985 THROUGH 2017.
THAT’S 33 YEARS OF DATA.
AND WHAT DID HE FIND?
HE SAYS I WILL ILLEGALS WERE
AT LEAST 142% MORE LIKELY TO
BE CONVICTED OF A CRIME THAN
OTHER ARIZONANS.
THEY FOUND THEIR SENTENCES
WERE 10.5% LONGER THAN U.S.
CITIZENS DUE TO THE SEVERITY
OF THEIR CRIME.
HE FOUND THAT ILLEGALS WERE
163% MORE LIKELY TO BE
CONVICTED OF FIRST DEGREE
MURDER THAN U.S. CITIZENS;
168% MORE LIKELY TO BE
CONVICTED OF SECOND DEGREE
MURDER.
189.6% MORE LIKELY TO BE
CONVICTED OF MANSLAUGHTER.
ILLEGALS WERE MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO COMMIT SEXUAL
OFFENSES AGAINST MINORS,
SEXUAL ASSAULT, DUI AND
ARMED ROBBERY.
AND 45.4% OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WERE MORE LIKELY
THAN OTHER CRIMINALS TO HAVE
BEEN GANG MEMBERS.
MY GOODNESS.
HERE’S A SMATTERING OF HOW
JUST IN THE PAST WEEK
ILLEGALS HAVE ADDED TO THE,
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
ON MONDAY, IN HARTFORD,
CONNECTICUT WHERE I COME
FROM.
A MEXICAN ILLEGAL PLED
GUILTY TO BEING PART OF A
HEROIN RING THAT EXTENDED TO
ALABAMA, CONNECTICUT, RHODE
ISLAND, OHIO, AND, GUESS
WHAT?
HE IS A BOOMER RANG VISITOR.
WEIGHS ALREADY DEPORTED BACK
IN 2014.
THEN THERE IS THIS CHARMER
SAL DOOR GOMENTDZ LOPSZ
MONTGOMERY COUNTY MARYLAND
RIGHT BY WHERE I’M
BROADCASTING FROM.
THE SALVADORIAN ILLEGAL WAS
URINATING IN PUBLIC LOVELY
WHEN A BYSTANDER TRIED TO
CONVINCE HIM TO PULL UP HIS
PANTS AND FIND A BATHROOM.
INSTEAD HE PULLED A BOX
CUTTER OUT AND STARTED
SLASHING AT THE POOR MAN’S
THROAT.
THERE IS A LOT OF GASHES
THERE NOW.
LAST WEEK THREE DREAMERS
WERE ARRESTED IN THREE
DIFFERENT SMUGGLING CASES,
ALL WERE DACA RECIPIENTS.
THEY WERE SMUGGLING HUMAN
BEINGS.
TWO WERE NABBED IN
CALIFORNIA AND ONE IN
ARIZONA.
AND THIS A HEARTBREAKER.
FIVE DAYS AGO IN RIO VISTA,S
AT THE TEXAS, A YOUNG MOTHER
OF TWO JENNIFER SMITH ON THE
WAY TO PICK UP HER KIDS AT
SCHOOL WAS KILLED IN A
HORRIFIC CAR CRASH BY
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT MARTINEZ
RAMIREZ, 32 YEARS OLD.
HE WAS DRUNK THIS PAST
SUNDAY MANY OF HAVE YOU
HEARD INDIANA COLTS
LINEBACKER EDWIN JACKSON AND
HIS UBER DRIVER WAS KILLED
ALIEN.
37-YEAR-OLD MANUEL.
THE DOJ ANNOUNCING IN JUST
THE LAST HOUR THAT THEY WILL
BRING FEDERAL CHARGES
AGAINST THE GUATEMALAN
PROVING ONCE AGAIN THAT JEFF
SESSIONS, ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND DOJ ARE MOVING QUICKLY
TO RIGHTS WRONGS OF THE PAST
WHEN IT COMES TO ILLEGAL
CRIME GOING UNPUNISHED.
NO MORE.
THIS HAS TO STOP.
LOOK AT THESE CASES.
THIS IS JUST A FEW.
JUST THE LAST WEEK.
CAN DO A WHOLE SHOW ON THIS.
WE REALLY START TO THINK
ABOUT IT.
IT’S TOTAL INSANITY.
WE HAVE ENOUGH PROBLEMS IN
OUR COUNTRY WITH DRUGS, THE
OPIOID EPIDEMIC.
>> ALCOHOL, CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY.
WE SURE DO NOT NEED ANYMORE.
AND, YES, OF COURSE, ALL
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE NOT
CRIMINALS.
BUT, FRANKLY THAT’S NOT THE
POINT.
BECAUSE THAT’S OF LITTLE
COMFORT TO JENNIFER SMITH’S
SON OR EDWIN JACKSON’S
MOTHER OR THE THOUSANDS OF
AMERICANS WHOSE NAMES YOU DO
NOT KNOW.
WHOSE LIVES WILL NEVER BE
THE SAME AGAIN BECAUSE OUR
GOVERNMENT WAS UNWILLING OR